au canada chaque foyer jette environ 140
kilos de nourriture chaque année c'est
l'équivalent de 1000 centres de l'arc
s'en va directement la poubelle d'où
l'idée du défi 0 gaspille organisé par
le chic frigo sans fric et la
transformer et il suffit de s'inscrire
sur le site web du défi ensuite vous
recevrez chaque mois une infolettre avec
des astuces et des recettes pour
apprendre à ne plus gaspiller le
gaspillage alimentaire ce n'est pas qu'à
la maison ça se passe tout au long de la
chaîne alimentaire un tiers de la
nourriture produite dans le monde finit
dans la poubelle ce qui contribue au
changement climatique selon le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat giec
quelques petits gestes à la maison
peuvent donc faire collectivement toute
la différence